bueno hasta ahorita hemos hecho muchas
rotaciones alrededor del eje de las
equis es hora de empezar con rotaciones
alrededor del eje de las íes cual vamos
a intentarlo entonces no lo voy a tomar
mi lado que antes ya no esté como
siempre va a ser bien que las 10 y estén
bien las equis y ahora voy a tomar una
función a una función sencilla para
empezar como tenemos hecho siempre y voy
a tomar la función que igual a equis
cuadrada cuál sería salvamos a
utilizarla bastante bien entonces voy a
dibujar la función que igual es cuadrada
es algo muy parecido a esto y bueno esto
es elegir las íes estas ligeras x y voy
a decir que esta función de igual al que
es cuadrada lo voy a llamar un poco más
general y le voy a poner
fx la idea de llamar a esta función fx
es para crear la teoría de una forma más
general y bueno igual que en el caso
anterior cuando quiera vamos alrededor
del eje las equis voy a tomar un
intervalo voy a tomar un intervalo para
ese intervalo hacerlo girar alrededor
del eje de la cra entonces pongamos que
me tomo
punto 0 al punto que está en general lo
puedo hacer mejor al punto 1 este esta
área es la que yo voy a querer girar
alrededor del eje de las íes solamente
esta área es lo que voy a hacer es girar
la alrededor del eje de las 10 y como
vamos a hacer eso bueno primero voy a
intentar dibujarlo así que a recuerden
mis clases de dibujo nosotros buenas
esto no me gusta mejor voy a utilizar la
herramienta de los círculos bien y este
va a ser mi base yo no voy a intentar
ser la cara superior no me gusta no
quedo alineado mejor pero me voy a
dibujar la cara lateral y voy a estar a
una altura aquí una altura acá de la
misma longitud y la idea es que ahora
voy a poner ya la
la base superior con un círculo entonces
voy a juntar estos dos y ya quedó está
aquí perfecto mi cilindro pero darse
cuenta que no era el cilindro lo que me
sale al girar mi área alrededor del eje
de la siesta yo lo que quiero es como un
cilindro pero que adentro tenga un hueco
por qué pues porque solamente tengo una
parte sólida al yo girar esta área
alrededor del eje de la siesta es como
si estuviera un cilindro por fuera y por
adentro como un plato hondo como un
tazón si parecido a un tazón esto es lo
que me sale o bueno el tratan de
visualizarlo esto es lo que me saldría
este año girar esta función alrededor
del eje darias de hecho mi meditación
tiene por adentro la figura de la
parábola de la parábola igual a equis
cuadrada en este caso recuerda que
dibujar no siempre es el problema más
difícil ya resolverlo no lo es tanto
entonces espero que lo hayan podido
visualizar bueno pero cómo resolvemos
este problema para resolver este
problema darse cuenta que no podemos
hacerlo
que hacíamos antes al girar alrededor
del eje de las x puesto que no
obtendríamos el mismo resultado entonces
en este caso voy a utilizar un nuevo
método es el método de los casquillos
pero que lo casquillo bueno lo primero
que quiero que vean es imagínense que
tomamos un venta nulo como siempre aquí
en nuestra área y que el punto inicial
del rectángulo de la base del rectángulo
es x1 por lo tanto mi altura del
rectángulo va a ser efe x 1 y este
rectángulo lo voy a girar alrededor del
eje de las 10 este va a ser mi casquillo
así que pues vamos a intentar dibujar
voy a suponer primero voy a utilizar
otra vez la herramienta de los círculos
entonces voy a decir que este va a ser
mi base superior y ahora me falta
dibujar la base inferior también
entonces dibuje primero los dos lados
así y ya que tienen la misma altura voy
a intentar dibujar también en la parte
inferior la base entonces pongamos que
esta es la base voy a contar los lados
para que para que me den presión bien ya
lo tengo aquí es como un como un
cilindro pero hueco es como un casquillo
desde ellos el casquillo hoy pareció el
anillo entonces voy a ver que la parte
exterior de este anillo pues es
completamente sólida por eso lo estoy
dibujando aquí esta parte es
completamente sólida mientras que el
interior es vacío tiene un cierto grosor
y después en el interior pues está hueco
los voy a ponerle un color distinto para
que parezca que está el hueco bien
ahora me voy a preguntar qué va a pasar
con este castillo como saco yo el
volumen de este castillo pues bueno
primero darse cuenta que tiene una
altura de fx entonces voy a poner con
color amarillo la altura es f x 1 donde
x su novedad el punto arbitrario que
habíamos tomado y ahora me pregunta va a
ser como lo calculó el área o la
superficie exterior de mi anillo la
superficie que está afuera de mi anillo
bueno para sacarla lo que necesitamos es
un poco de conocimiento de geometría
básica y recordar cómo se sacaba el
perímetro de un círculo el perímetro de
un círculo pues se sacaba muy fácil era
dos veces pi por el radio y si a éste
dos veces por el rayo lo multiplicamos
por la altura pues ya tenemos entonces
mi superficie pero bueno la pregunta va
a ser quién es el radio yo lo que
quisiera saber es cuál es el radio de
este castillo pero el radio este
casquillo es ni más ni menos la
distancia que hay del 0 a x 1 o sea x 1
entonces yo ya tendría que el radio en
este caso es x1
entonces si ya tengo el radio yo puedo
sustituyendo es decir que estos dos por
x1 ok y si ya tendremos el perímetro
pues ya sacar el área de la superficie
que dibuje aquí ya es muy sencillo es
más voy a sacar la fórmula para sacar el
área de la superficie que era el
perímetro x fm x 1 entonces pongamos lo
área de la superficie es igual a la
circunferencia o el perímetro de la
circunferencia multiplicado por la
altura o sea 2000 x x 1 y esto lo voy a
multiplicar por efe x1 bien pero atrás
de que vamos no vamos tras el área de la
superficie lo que realmente quiero es el
volumen de este casquillo
pero para sacar es bueno vender este
casquillo lo que puede necesitar es
multiplicarlo por el ancho del casquillo
y el ancho del casquillo era la base del
rectángulo que es de x nuestro
famosísimo de x que sale tantas veces en
la integral y recuerden que lo que yo
quería hacer era que éste de x hacerlo
infinitamente pequeño infinitamente
delgado para tomar así la integral bueno
es más voy a dibujar de una vez el
rectángulo para no perdernos este
rectángulo hito que propiedades tiene
bueno tiene un grosor de equis y tiene
una altura de fx uno por aquí estaba x
uno y lo voy a dibujar aquí estaba x uno
que dan la distancia del origen a pues
adjunto x 1 entonces si ya tengo yo que
mi grosor es de x lo que voy a querer
hacer es la suma de todos estos
casquillos pues entonces voy a tomar el
volumen del casquillo que es el volumen
del casquillo
bueno pues sería dos veces el pib x x 1
que multiplica a efe x 1 es decir el
área de la superficie exterior de mi
casquillo ya esto que tengo que
multiplicar por de x que era mi grosor y
espero que a estas alturas del vídeo ya
haya algo adentro de sus entrañas que se
vaya moviendo y dándoles la idea de a
dónde vamos porque realmente yo lo que
quiero sumar todos mis casquillos y
hacer el grosor de mis casquillos
infinita
pequeño es decir hacer la idea o la
noción de la integral sobre todos mis
casquillos la suma de cada uno de mis
monumentos de mis casquillos entonces el
volumen total quién va a ser pues es va
a ser la integral porque es la suma de
todos mis casquillos de quién pues el
volumen de cada uno de mis casquillos o
sea 2 pi que multiplica a x1 pero aquí
sólo era una equis arbitraria entonces
como yo lo quiero alrededor de todas las
equis pues voy a tomar a x que
multiplica a efe de x y esto x de x y
ojo esta integral es definida en un
intervalo es así como ya tenemos la
fórmula para sacar el volumen t mi sueño
de revolución al girarlo alrededor del
eje de mis x pero vamos en este caso
particular y acabar de una vez con este
caso que habíamos tomado es 2000 por la
integral de 0 1 por x por fx pero fx es
x cuadrada entonces es x cuadrada y
ahora bien simplificando y haciendo una
integral me queda que esto es x cúbica y
la primitiva de x cúbica pues es x 4a
y todo esto lo vamos a evaluar entre 1 y
0 pues bien vamos a evaluarlo el 1 que
le queda pues esto va a ser 2 piqué
multiplica a 1 la cuarta que es 1 entre
cuatro que es 4 osea un cuarto y en 0
pues no hay necesidad solamente 0 y 2
por un cuarto es un medio entonces al
final me va a terminar quedando pi
medios y este es el volumen que
queríamos alquilar alrededor del eje de
la siesta así que nos estaremos viendo
en el siguiente vídeo